حسنًا ، أنت تعلم أنه إذا نظرت إلى الأرقام
الإجمالية ، فإن الحالات لا تزال
تتزايد ، لكن السرعة التي
نشهد بها حالات جديدة قد انخفضت قليلاً
كما تعلم أندرسون ، فالأرقام المبكرة ومن
الصعب دائمًا جمع هذه المواقف
أيضًا  كثيرًا ولكن من الواضح أنك
تريد أن ترى وتيرة
استمرار هذه الحالات الجديدة
في الانخفاض ، لذلك تريد أن ترى هذا
الاتجاه يستمر ولكن ما اعتقدت أنه
مثير للاهتمام حقًا كان هناك هذه الدراسة الكبيرة التي
تضم 44000 مريض نظروا إليها
من المحتمل أن يكون هناك الكثير من المرضى ،
لكنهم كانوا قادرين على دراسة
44000 ، 80 بالمائة منهم لم يكن لدى أندرسون
أي أعراض أو أعراض قليلة من
المتوقع أن يتعافى تمامًا ، لذلك هذا جيد
كما تعلمون وهذا النوع من الملاءمة مع
ما نراه كثيرًا  من الأشخاص الذين تم
تشخيص إصابتهم بالعدوى ولكن
ليس لديهم أعراض بالفعل ، هناك حوالي 14 15
بالمائة حيث يعاني الأشخاص من مرض أكثر خطورة
بما في ذلك الالتهاب الرئوي.
المرضى الذين يقولون إنهم ماتوا بسبب هذا ،
لكن ضع في اعتبارك أن تحصل على هذا الرقم 2٪
وهو عدد الوفيات مقارنة
بعدد الأشخاص المصابين ، لا أعتقد
أننا نعرف حقًا أندرسون كم عدد الأشخاص
المصابين هناك هناك
أعراض محتملة لم يتم اختبارها أبدًا  لذلك
لن تعرف ذلك ، أعتقد أن
هذا يخفض نسبة الوفيات كثيرًا وكيف
يمكن مقارنته بالفيروسات الأخرى التي تعرفها
من حيث الوفيات وهل
هناك أي طريقة لمقارنتها ، نعم ، أعني
أنه يمكنك إلقاء نظرة على ما تعلمه  كل شيء بدءًا
من h1n1 Zika SARS والمرايا هي الأشياء
التي غالبًا ما يقارن الناس بها
لأنهم أيضًا جزء من
عائلة الفيروسات نفسها وعائلة فيروس كورونا
ومرة أخرى أنت تعرف أنك وقضيت وقتًا في
ذه المواقف حيث نرى ال
فزة  من هذه العوامل الممرضة من
الحيوانات إلى البشر ، هذا هو كيف
تدخل معظم هذه العوامل الممرضة إلى البشر
، لقد حدث سبع مرات
في الماضي مع فيروس كورونا ، كان اثنان منهم يمثلان
مشكلة السارس
والمرايا  باللون الأحمر لأولئك الذين يبدو أن هذا
أقل فتكًا بكثير ،
فقط تحدث معي قليلاً أعتقد
أنني قاطعتك بوقاحة عن الفيروس
نفسه ، كيف يختلف عما تعرفه
بعد ذلك عن الأنفلونزا ثم الفيروسات الأخرى أو بعد
ذلك تعرف السارس أكثر من الفيروسات الأخرى نحن  لقد
رأينا أن هذا فيروس قابل للانتقال بدرجة كبيرة ،
فهو ليس قابلاً للانتقال مثل
الحصبة على سبيل المثال ، ولكن يبدو أنه
أكثر قابلية للانتقال من السارس
وربما من الأنفلونزا معدل وفياته
لا نعرف على وجه اليقين حتى الآن لأننا لا
نفهم حقًا  النطاق الكامل
للأشخاص الذين أصيبوا بالعدوى ،
وهذا شيء نحاول متابعته
الآن عن طريق اختبار الأجسام المضادة ، فالكثير من
الأشخاص لا تظهر عليهم أعراض أو يعانون من
مرض خفيف جدًا ، ولا نفعل ذلك حتى نحصل
على هذا المقام ، كل ما نراه هو
قمة الجبل الجليدي هؤلاء الأشخاص
يعانون من مرض شديد حيث
لدينا نوع من الخداع من اختبار Tory ،
لذلك من غير المعروف سبب عدم ظهور أعراض على بعض الأشخاص الذين
لا يظهرون
كثيرًا ربما لديهم القليل من الوعاء أو
نحو ذلك  لكنهم لا يفعلون ذلك ، لا ينتهي
بهم الأمر بالموت ، ولا ينتهي بهم الأمر إلى
دخول المستشفى ، لا ما زالت الأيام الأولى
هي ما نفعله عادةً هو أننا
نحاول تقييم هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين يعانون من
حالات طبية أساسية هل
لديهم مرض مزمن  الحساسية لسرطان الرئة الانسدادي ،
أي نوع من الأشياء
التي قد تجعلهم عرضة للإصابة
بمرض شديد ولكن لدينا الكثير من الأشخاص على
سبيل المثال أو العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية الذين
يُفترض أنهم يتمتعون بصحة جيدة ولياقة بدنية جيدة ، وقد شهدنا
كما رأيت بعض الوفيات المأساوية هناك
إليكم صغيرًا آخر وكان هذا 40
نظرة على النافذة في معظم البط -
معلقة هناك وهذا يعني أن العمل ليس
جيدًا كان هناك الكثير من
الطاولات الفارغة داخل متجر chibi n go noodle في
New York Bo CAI في شارع Baxter
وهو ليس الوحيد الذي أمشي  حول المنطقة ،
أرى السوق فارغًا ، أرى في الواقع أن جميع
الحي الصيني قد شهد انخفاضًا بنسبة 40 في
المائة في الأعمال التجارية ، ولا أحد
يشتري الألعاب والحلي الشهيرة
بالإضافة إلى الحلوى اللذيذة بسبب
الخوف من كورونا  الفيروس على الرغم
من عدم وجود حالات مؤكدة
في المدينة ، لا أعرف لماذا هذه الحالة
اليوم تعاونت شراكة الحي الصيني
مع امرأتين في المجلس المحلي
لتشجيع الناس على إعادة الأعمال
إلى الحي الصيني ، نحن فرصة للسياسيين
لجعل هذه الشرطة بثبات
منذ ذلك الحين  بدأ تفشي فيروس كورونا
مرة أخرى داخل مطعم n gos ، لقد رأينا بعض
علامات عودة الحياة إلى طبيعتها خلال اندفاع الغداء اليوم ،
وتساعد حملة التوعية
كثيرًا ،
لذا فإن الحفاظ على الحقيقة بعيدًا عن الناس